well first of all as I said off camera
I've been a fan of yours for a really
long time I'm very happy to finally get
to talk to you thank you um what listen
uh man I have a lot of questions okay
what is it like for obviously you had
ideas for actors for this movie what is
it like handing the script to them and
knowing that if they like it they're
gonna you know maybe they're gonna do it
like right what are you sleeping the
night before yeah I mean you know I've
done this a while and you know I so I've
experienced that moment often you know I
think I think there's usually there's a
read and there's a conversation usually
is what happens and and you know so what
you have to hope is that is that the
experience of the read makes them want
to do it and then they want to get on
the phone or meet in person to make sure
you're not crazy I also want to have you
know do that check a normalcy check on
on some level because I don't believe
that that you know we have to suffer to
make great art and I just want to do my
best work and get home to my family and
so I want to make sure that people's
priorities are in the in the right place
so but certainly there have been moments
in in my career where you know landing
an actor can be the difference between
the project going and not going and you
know there's some stress involved in
that but it's not a hardship one of the
things I thought was really cool about
the film is the way you use the aspect
ratio to sort of inform the audience in
the mental state yeah was that something
that you had to is that it's an unusual
thing to be able to pull off was it
something you had to fight for or did
they go along did the studio go along
with it right at the get-go no they were
excited you know in the first the first
meeting I had with the executives at at
Fox Searchlight it occurred to me as we
were talking in how do you make
something subjective where you go on
this journey with her you don't sit back
and and and judge her for the choices
that she makes it occurred to me that
that that would that could be a
technique that we used and and they they
responded to it right away I think they
liked the idea you know I think they
came to me with this project because
because I experiment
and because because I take creative
risks you know visually so you know I
think that they were excited that I was
that I was excited for her I really
enjoyed that hospital shot where you
know she's sort of floating right I
don't want to say why yeah how did you
come up with that shot and talk a little
bit about filming it well yeah we we we
refer to it as a kind of infinite zoom I
was trying to design in this film the
whole way through a subjective
experience and she gets this news that
that her grandmother has had a stroke
who's raised her and she goes to the
hospital to see her and you know who
among us in a moment of crisis can
really remember getting from one place
to another right you just that you go
into this crisis mode and I think that
that I wanted to represent that with her
which is she's lost in thought and she's
not paying any attention to what's
happening around her and it had to be an
emotional moment as well which is why we
used the song and and the music in in
that spot to create an experience for
the audience where it's not literal but
it's it's magical sure I'm always
curious about the editing the the
editing room because it's the final
rewrite it's where everything comes
together so how long was your first cut
compared to the finished film you know
it wasn't that much longer I think it
was about maybe 10 minutes longer so
yeah it wasn't it wasn't bad and you
know I mean I i I'm an ensemble
storyteller and you know I would say
with those 10 minutes ended up being
were you know were point-of-view shifts
that ultimately in in the movie was not
where the audience wanted to be so you
know so really it it changed a lot but
at the length of it didn't didn't really
change that dramatically sure who did
you who's in your first
friends-and-family screening that sort
of that you trusted for honest feedback
and
they honest with you yes I hope so you
know I showed I showed my wife first
you know we had had a lot of
conversations before I made this movie
about why did why do I want to make this
movie and and I think I was able to
articulate my point of view on that
pretty well but the best argument for
why I wanted to make it was the movie
itself and and I think at the at the end
of it you know she understood very
clearly why why I wanted to make this
movie and you know it was very helpful
in in helping me from an objective place
really understand the impact that the
story was having sure there are if I'm
not mistaken there are three distinct
color patterns in the film or am I wrong
about this I don't know tell me what you
got
oh no I um the there you have a very you
designed this very specifically you had
a real vision for this thing yeah talk a
little bit about in the pre-production
that kind of thing where you're thinking
about the color design you're thinking
about all that stuff yeah well a lot of
it again it's it's a you know I mean
color is emotion and music is emotion
and and you know there there there is
there's a metaphor of transformation
obviously throughout this whole film and
so the question is visually how are you
creating that that experience for the
audience you know there's about a
butterfly metaphor here obviously but
you know what you learn when you read
about how a caterpillar turns into a
butterfly is that it's a very violent
process and the caterpillar liquefies
literally destroys itself in order to
become this beautiful thing which became
more of a metaphor for the journey I
also knew that that as the story at a
certain point the story was going to
darken as her psychological decline took
place and I thought well I don't want
the movie to get dark and the butterfly
allowed me to say there's a moment in
the film where she's left her husband
and she hasn't brought any clothes with
her and she goes through her grandmother
stuff and she finds this very colorful
wardrobe as she's transforming the movie
gets brighter as the
subject gets darker and you know there's
another production design metaphor of
our husband you know stripping wallpaper
from the walls and it's a very you know
striped and and and staid pattern and
underneath it as are all these flowers
this idea of what's underneath the
surface of someone you know it was about
that sense of stripping back the
exterior to get to who Nataly character
really was I know I'm gonna run out of
time with you actually one last question
what was before filming began no matter
how much you never have enough time you
never not have enough money no matter
what movie you're making what was the
thing you were really nervous about
being able to pull off with the
limitations you had well so this is a
movie that that has a space sequence and
it has an underwater training sequence
right and if you think about what it
takes to pull those things off you know
in a 35 day schedule probably 14 to 18
of those days were those sequences which
are about 15 minutes of the movie so
that means you have about 20 days to
make the whole movie on top of that so I
should mention for people that are
watching that's insane
yes a very ambitious schedule yeah and
you know I mean I come from Fargo and
from television so you know the days are
always impossible but we do them anyway
but I had certainly hoped and moving to
moving to features that I would have a
more realistic schedule you know where
it's like we're shooting three pages a
day and that's not that's not how it
ended up but you know it's I signed out
for it so it's nobody's fault with my
own but that was the challenge of it was
to make sure that we had enough time to
tell the story and not just blow all the
time on the eye candy completely um I
have to I love Fargo I have to bring
that up with you yes I believe you're in
when do you start filming the fourth
season is it filming
no we start on October 15th and is that
the kind of show where you have most of
the scripts done or how does that
because I've heard like with Game of
Thrones a at all 10 scripts yes with
Fargo how much are the scripts done
before filming begins and how much is it
sort of like you have the whole thing
really figure it out but we only have
like five
scripts the ladder the you know it
depends year-to-year the first year I
had eight out of ten the second year I
had probably six out of ten you know
this year I'm in the five in the five
range you know some of it is just one
thing to another thing to another thing
you know and then I I took a vacation
because I think I deserved a vacation I
agree yeah and then I came back and and
you know I'm directing the first block
so you know in a perfect world I would
be writing scripts but instead I'm
prepping the show but you know we mapped
everything out I you know I know the
journey and the writing process for me
is is not a belaboured lengthy one so
I'm not worried about it yet I
understand I already have to go but is
there anything you can tease about the
season
well the cast's is incredible and and I
would say it's twice at least twice the
size of any other story that we've told
both financially and and you know just
the scope of it and the scale of it and
the period of it you know it's you know
there's no reason to do this again
unless I think it can be the best one
yet and I I think that I cannot wait to
see it Congrats on everything thank you
pleasure to finally meet you yes
seriously